jean daniel et ses portes c'est
effectivement l'opinion est pourtant
favorable à une sélection d'après les
derniers sondages et y compris les
sondages en tout cas ça dépend ce qu'on
veut tailler des mots qui sont des mots
qui crée en général la tension le fait
que l'apb fonctionner la réponse est non
de manière extrêmement majoritaire chez
l'ensemble des français avaient
globalement le sentiment qu'ils avaient
une injustice c'est à dire que c'est pas
forcément parce qu'on avait fait une
bonne scolarité c'est pas forcément même
parce qu'on avait eu des bons résultats
voire une mention au bac qui pouvait y
avoir la tentation en cohérence avec la
manière dont l'étudiant où le lycéen
avait pu se comporter dans quelle est
cette forme de critiques de la part de
la part des français pour autant quand
on regarde les termes on sait qu'il ya
des termes qui suscite des tensions
fortes et des français globalement au
sentiment que le bac doit quand même
être la première entrée vers
l'enseignement supérieur si on a le
sentiment que bahia d'une manière ou de
l'autre pas la possibilité pour tous les
français notamment quelle que soit leur
catégorie sociale de pouvoir accéder à
l'enseignement supérieur il ya une
tension il peut y avoir effectivement
des critiques fortes qui peuvent être
émis à l'égard des différents
gouvernements
il ya quand même une notion d'égalité
qui existe dans la série française
on voit peu elle traverse de manière
assez nette l'ensemble du regard à
l'égard des politiques publiques qui
sont établis s lorsqu'on a le sentiment
qu'il ya une rupture d'égalité une
rupture d'égalité des chances dans ce
contexte là il peut y avoir une
rebuffade assez fort de la part des
français